[Music]
three two one action hey guys welcome
back to off the record where we talk
about whatever we want but first thank
you to our sponsor upstart upstart is
the first artificial intelligence
lending platform designed to improve
access to affordable credit almost all
lenders use FICO based models to decide
who is approved for credit and at what
interest rate however upstart goes
beyond the traditional credit score when
assessing your creditworthiness they
reward you based on things like your
education and job history in the form of
a smarter interest rate upstart is a
great way to get your first loan and
even if you haven't qualified for
traditional loans it can help you on
your journey to providing your
creditworthiness to proving your
creditworthiness they make it fast
simple and easy to check your rate in
just a few minutes the best part once
the loan is approved and accepted most
people get their funds the very next
business day say well over three hundred
thousand people have used up start to
pay off credit cards or achieve their
financial goals see why upstart is
ranked number one in their category with
over three hundred businesses on
Trustpilot and hurry up to upstart
dot-com slash record to find out how low
your up start rate is checking your rate
only takes a few minutes and won't
affect your credit so go ahead and click
in a description box below you'll see
the link of SAR comm slash record ya fix
your credit I was just in Vegas and uh
speaking of credit I was [ __ ] Nicky
and oh okay you do know this story it's
actually the hospital yes I know wait
she went to the hospital or or she got
she had sex with her in the end I put
her in the hospital thank you thank you
maybe you can tell that one you had sex
with your wife and you broke her vagina
no I wish better I tried so broke her
butthole
I tried no so yeah I you know we're
trying to make a baby engine so we got
it was pretty rough and but but it was
like we were it was consent
and I was [ __ ] her I was [ __ ] her
on her back and then I like picked her
up and flipped her over into a
nightstand oh oh did you get her on the
head I got her like her lip like just
right oh my god and I mean what [ __ ]
never yeah do it everywhere I've gonna
cut her lip yeah it was a deeper cut in
her lip coffee-table cut her lip the the
corner of the honey did you get to
finish at least no I ran into the
bathroom with a boner and I have had
blue balls so how and that's cool well
actually I busted once put down but I
was one for my second she she was she
was crying obviously quiet right away
right yeah she couldn't handle it was
terrified I was parents go to the urgent
care
it took a rector joke area they probably
see some crazy [ __ ] I could see
so basically when it happened there's
blood there's blood like going down from
her face and psych looks pretty nuts and
looks like I cleaned her up a little bit
like this blood like here and [ __ ] and I
was like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
and she's like my like her under eye
socket she's like my under eye hurts and
I was like girl do to this chick cuz the
whole table just smacked her cuz yeah so
sure we don't know the extent of
anything so it was basically like gab
taking innards were y'all intoxicated
what did you do did you have to get a
Bueller's or did you call uber I called
uber well no we got into a taxi and that
was like you took a surgery care and
then I got there and I'm phone the
papers and like what happened and I was
like we have a disagreement and you
decided to beat her
I was like I was like cuz like on the
way there were you like this looks
really bad on know it does but at the
same time it's [ __ ] Vegas dude like
that's not the craziest thing they
probably say no the craziest [ __ ]
story that they've heard I was there
right so so they take her in the ER
while I'm fill out paperwork and I
didn't see them take her in there and so
then the nurses like don't wanna go and
with your wife and I was like yeah
where'd they go and she's like oh let me
find out so they were already in there
with Niki and they're you know they're I
told Nikki go in there I was like dude I
can go to [ __ ] jail for this [ __ ] I
was like but tell them everything tell
them everything that happened to be
honest because I didn't know what the
extent of any of the damage i legit
thought that maybe something that is
high or could be like a cracked skull I
didn't [ __ ] know right just get
x-rays that are you flipped Dupree when
you try to make her do like a 720 so I
had her on her back and I'm and I was
trying to get her on the doggie and then
yeah the nightstand got in the way
yeah damn nice thing came out of nowhere
I mean it was very dark in there by the
way and then I don't have the best
decision I think that's known oh I think
that just when you don't have any right
now with my in-laws it's her family
that's her old man her [ __ ] grandma
they think you beat her of the truth
during sex kinda I was like I'd be so
embarrassed I'd make up a lie and be
like I beat her it's hard for me to log
he stops when someone that speaks
Tagalog
no no no just that's just your grandma
everyone else speaks speaks English cuz
they're all military man they could the
mom was like you are all learning
English so okay so I basically would I
get her back oh they put this glue in
there that actually sealed it up pretty
damn good like super glue is awesome
yeah and then um yes she and then the
pain went away in her head and stuff
thank God and she's actually doing bits
in the [ __ ] Hospital that's good
she's like there's my abuser all [ __ ]
the nurse is laughing her ass off and
I'm like I feel like she's just Christ -
one more time like oh my god yeah my and
it's game over right that's what I'm
saying that's my style
yeah she's Master Hand too right so it
looks like you got
I know exactly look if I had a bloody
hand or something I'll can you imagine
dude okay so yeah so then Nicky I take
Nicky back to the hotel and then she
goes to sleep immediately and then I'm
like well we're all supposed to meet
downstairs and I don't want to be shady
tomorrow when it's like she shows up
with a [ __ ] card so I go downstairs
and I'm I'm so [ __ ] tall that
everyone sees me immediately coming off
the elevator cuz I was like maybe I can
go get a sandwich or some [ __ ]
they're like Steve what happened yeah
it's like that so then her mom's like
hey where's Nicky and I'm like oh man
here we go oh my god to fight the table
on why I'm like we had a pretty crazy
night actually she's in college you guys
lose and I'm like yeah right so then I
was like I was like you know so Nicky I
had take her to the you know you have to
just open with that right I'm like she's
fine I had to take her to the to the ER
or whatever and moms of course I don't
like she's old she's fine she's a
flipper over doing doggy style and she
goes oh honey that got you styled so
with that I just said I just said that
so Nicky was drunk as she was and like
she we were doing things and she hit the
nightstand
that's Alyssa that's a pretty good
explanation thank you she's like you see
this car yeah so yeah it was pretty
weird because then after that I'm I'm
watching her grandma played penny slots
and like you know her mom's just like
talking to me about what happened and
I'm like yeah this is more here
we're with Grandma like and the old man
was next to me so I didn't want to be
like hey I was penetrating your daughter
if he's that Explorer even though you
guys are married it's still awkward oh
yeah I just don't and you don't you know
what disrespect the guy it's more
information that he needs to know
realistically yes my future son-in-law
or whatever yeah you know if he did that
to me I'd be like you know [ __ ] check
yourself I'd be like this yeah you
exactly it's just about respect I'm not
saying don't [ __ ] my daughter I'm saying
like don't tell me about it right now
maybe you're everything I do
future your future I produce good sex
objects and then he's like then what
then what huh then what no this is the
the father son-in-law handshake oh I
don't know make out whoa so my
son-in-law is gonna get ready for a
make-out session with me you might not
get a son-in-law was that middle was at
the beginning of the trip or the end of
the trip like how long second night okay
out of three nights or no about four
nights so that was on Thanksgiving yeah
giving it was on Thanksgiving
Thanksgiving and then I was so I was so
[ __ ] upset that I did that to heard
that I went on a walk after oh man I
just well cuz I my nerves are like my
[ __ ] internal energies is bouncing
all over the place yeah she's up there
passed out already that was the second
that was my second one so then yeah so
then I actually ended up I was walking
around a bunch and then I ended up at a
Denny's and I ate Denny Thanksgiving
that's on the strip on the corner yeah
because
yeah I bet all the other degenerates are
judging the [ __ ] out of yeah thanks Ken
I'm like look at me I'm a [ __ ] wife
beater eating at Denny's alone on
Thanksgiving is that what you when they
were entered in is that what you said I
don't like your table for one it does
beautiful wife beater please family
although they were all there all I going
to bed by 11:00 yeah grandma are you
kidding me no I grant no [ __ ] OB will
stay at those spots till he died good
point this one didn't okay but she did
this funny thing where she touches so
you know how you have the all the
different things coming down yeah he
touches what she wants next before she
can hold our does it work her thing no
ritual wash your ass right I bet did you
see have you seen the like big like
Buddha's that they have in some of the
hotels and stuff dude that [ __ ] belly
has rubbed the [ __ ] oh it's like good
luck to go rub it so like [ __ ]
scraped off like I saw an inch of this
dudes belly touch it before they go when
I landed in four four that's when I saw
like the texts and stuff is like it's
just on Nikki's face yeah she's like all
crying with the cut she's like guys it's
not Bora Bora like what I was like oh
but like by then I had already gotten
the whole story okay I just look at the
picture like what happened
that's a funny ass like sex injury I
couldn't speak to them so was she gonna
look like she got cleft palate and [ __ ]
now she it looks good it's really healed
quickly to the glue she's tired yeah she
doesn't need any like cosmetic surgery
anything's not bad no no no no stitches
so yeah the exam yeah that's like they
just touched the bone they're like they
just checked it out yeah that's probably
good bruise or something I don't even
think it was a bruise I think it was in
the moment she just felt trauma maybe or
smack their heads and I got you know
headache or whatever yeah did you guys
know money [ __ ] no I lost it
everything's a bad luck we cuz I lost it
[ __ ] I lost it craps I lost I mean I
just walked right right my friend just
told me or my boy Tyco just told me the
story of his buddy that had
bad luck and it's the worst luck that I
have ever heard but I also couldn't stop
from laughing cuz you sounded ridiculous
so his buddy
um just this last week he fell down onto
scissors I don't know how he falls down
onto scissors the scissors go through
his body and punctures his kidney oh so
now a leaky kidneys we have to go on
dialysis but because the scissors I
guess was dirty oh he got an infection
in where the kidney is and then the
butcher scissors I don't know that's
what would have happened you should have
happened to the home alone bandits and
then what happen is a poacher the kidney
this guy is on dialysis and then now his
heart rate is unstable Oh starts
dropping and he has also has an
infection oh she saying he might only
have like a week to live what what he's
okay now
no he doesn't know yet we're still it's
not bad for laughing but it just sounds
like a cartoon series of injuries right
like I've never heard of anyone falling
onto scissors Yeah right crazy we do so
many things that we should die yeah yeah
yeah we're just we don't yeah where the
scissors standing yeah I know it's like
this and just getting ready to chop you
down I'm gonna puncture of his flat
unless you there's like a bacteria on it
ready hold it by the thing maybe was
holding it like by the thing and then it
was pointed it is like oh maybe he was
being used in a final destination movie
Museum maybe that would explain what is
that is that the best experience at the
final destination Museum that or is that
the worst exactly good question living
it out it's like a [ __ ] poison arrow
yeah but I'm just like sometimes when
you have bad luck you really have now
yeah that's why it's like you can't
really be afraid of death yeah cuz it
just can come in the weirdest ways like
we did a Jay King news with this guy
taking out the trash and then he got a
little cut and that trash Jews went in
and then he had that blood infection and
he [ __ ] died yeah man [ __ ] that yeah
well the guy gets a parasite up his dick
yeah yeah you just gotta live life you
got you could die in you a dude
[ __ ] it well you will die yeah I mean
we're gonna die right so you might as
well live
my whole flip chicks in the nightstands
dude yeah well you can't do the greatest
part is that she will never let you live
this exactly what a story dude that's
what makes life interesting well she's
the best man that the fact that I was
that [ __ ] I was like I was like on
the verge of like being like [ __ ] me
I'll kill myself or whatever I was like
[ __ ] sad and she calls you an abuser
and she do it
she's the best man she is the [ __ ]
best but she did that for me and she's
lifted me up and yeah she's a special
knocking you know she did and you can
see you can see way more about that too
on Nikki youtube.com slash Nikki and
Nikki's [ __ ] Janice cause of course got
bloggers and everything you abuser
additional camera oh yeah you can even
see the nightstand Wow
it's sad all their [ __ ] or anything or
doing I'm Jim that's one gram it was
like a circus are you afraid that when
you make the kid the spirits of that
area will Incept it because I believe
that every time the [ __ ] sperm hits
that egg right as soon as that magic
happens
the closest spirit by default gets to
enter that [ __ ]
so when I'm in Vegas I'm like you got to
always use a condom even if you're
trying to make kids at the moment well
would you want to make a kid then the
cabin
yeah let's going in a church like the
cabin oh and I said Doug happen yeah
like Doug heaven why cabin castle you
get some frontier men ghosts lumberjack
help me lumberjack oh I like that I like
that or a castaway yeah okay it's one of
the like top guys - not one of the guys
that they like oh he's weak and they
left them on the island
and something like that you could just
select a soul for your that would be
cool from like a drop-down menu and I I
look a Michael Jackson designer clothes
are you just get her pregnant at
Neverland that's weird
it's history that says yeah I bet you
believe it Brandon I don't know I don't
believe it I love MJ for his
entertainment value I don't want to
think anything else I don't want to
taint you don't want to think about him
laying in bed with children which he
admitted to on television yeah you don't
think about him what can't spread his
butt cheek looking backwards and saying
haha Peter Pan I'm just picturing
Jackson 5 Michael Jackson so I see in my
head I don't picture that either but I
know a lot of perverts that do Julianne
Joe you're not playing this game right
you're supposed to be in indignant that
I even said such a thing
sure and then you're supposed to wildly
protect this man putting your body in
his path yeah Joe he's my friend and my
best friend
there is no that stamp on his [ __ ]
thank you because he's never done
anything wrong but give him happiness
and love to the whole entire world and
everyone just keeps taking from him well
we will argue for their own petrol
only ok only on patreon that's where you
get the Michael Jackson argument
exclusive we will do a full deep dive
episode on Michael Jackson Oh why he
didn't do it
oh why he did it he did it yeah multiple
times with multiple kids
oh why he's innocent when you got money
like that everyone tries to take you for
everything
I think he's innocent of [ __ ] women
[Laughter]
how do you have kids I think they're
designer babies designer babies what's a
designer baby really you gotta kill ego
the injection mold that [ __ ] sperm
inside us a perfect egg yeah they were
in love they're loving they didn't have
kids no they had kids I love for five
months come on man you said read never
got pregnant we the kid is blade his
name is blanket no it's not
got off the window balcony that was the
one with the nanny looking lady
yeah the nanny lookin lady yeah the mom
is the many looking lady oh okay she
looks like good a a dead ringer for a
nanny that's the only baby I remember
and I say nanny because I think she was
legit like some kind of nanny situation
- no ex personally I think that he got
her pregnant that kind of [ __ ]
[Music]